hi everybody welcome back to cs224n um
the first just a couple of announcements
um originally this was going to be the
day when assignment 5 was due but um as
you've seen
we're giving you one extra day so it's
now due friday at 4 30. um we do realize
that assignment 5 has been a bit of a
tough challenge for many people though
we've been trying to help people out and
office hours and otherwise so i hope at
the end of the day it will seem like it
was a really good um learning experience
to really get some much more kind of
close hands-on look at how transformers
work rather than it simply being
loading up a transformer as a black
mystery box
after friday i guess there's no rest
since
we do really hope that you can sort of
basically immediately transitioned to
working on final projects since there's
basically four weeks to go on final
projects and in particular we're hoping
to get um feedback on your project
proposals back by next tuesday to help
that process or honor people we have to
get started on them soon um
and you know
um
it's just maybe a good um
moment to say that you know we do really
appreciate all the people have been
putting tons of effort into these
assignments and um we like that of all
the keyness we're seeing from the
students okay so with that out of the
way um today um i'm delighted to have
giving um today's lecture on neural
language generation antran boss lou
who's at present a postdoc at stanford
he's someone who's done a lot of work on
natural language generation in his
previous life
as a university of washington phd
student and next year he's going to be
taking up
a
position as a professor
in switzerland okay so welcome and tron
uh thanks chris that's a very uh kind
introduction
um it's it's it's great to be here uh
giving this lecture uh
cs224n
uh particularly on on one of my uh
favorite topics in in deep learning for
for nlp uh natural uh language
generation
and so hopefully by the end of this
lecture uh most of you will have at
least learned uh a bit about an lg with
deep learning and hopefully be motivated
to start doing some research on it or
launch a startup uh in nlg or perhaps go
work on it in a larger organization
okay
um
so to start i think it might be really
helpful to define what we meet at a at a
high level when we talk about natural
language generation because
you know over the last few years the
definition has actually sort of changed
and has really grown as a as a subfield
to
to really
encapsulate any part of nlp that
involves the the production of written
or spoken language
uh in other words if you're given some
inputs and your your goal is to generate
text to you know describe respond
translate or summarize that piece of
text
um
you know nlg really focuses on how you
can actually build a system that can
that can automatically produce a
coherent and and useful uh written piece
of text for for that human
for human consumption
um and it used to be a much more limited
research area uh since many tasks that
we now view as nlg problems didn't
actually involve uh much text production
uh prior to neural networks uh but now
that scope has expanded considerably and
we have this this this much larger area
uh to sort of work in
uh unfortunately we're not you know
quite yet at the level
of the types of aai and lg tools that
that we've seen in in pop culture and
that we like to imagine uh but we are
starting to see many areas where nlg
tools are are having a massive impact um
you know to start with machine
translation is kind of the the classical
example uh of of of an nlg task uh pat
you know these days uh ever since uh the
task moved to neural to neural networks
and a non-lg framework around 2014 or so
and now we've seen a rapid improvement
in the quality and applicability of
translation systems and in fact you can
often use google translate for most of
your kind of uh retail translation needs
um
as a good as a good starting point uh
similarly nlg technologies really
underpin some of the dialogue systems
that you might interact with on a daily
basis uh anytime you use let's say siri
alexa cortana google home bixby uh or
pretty much you know any other major
companies uh dialogue system there's a
good chance that there's a neural nlg
component embedded in that system that's
involved with with providing you an
answer to your query
and there's really still a ton of
progress to be made in this area and
it's led to some major companies to
actually crowdsource chatbot
technologies from researchers and
students such as yourself
uh to continue to try to make big
advances in this area
um we're also you know seeing uh lots of
nlg technologies uh you know used in
areas such as summarization uh where
systems often have to uh to to aggregate
information from potentially multiple
sources and rephrase
uh the most salient content in in a
shortened but still very engaging way uh
while our go-to example for
summarization is is generally related to
let's say generating news highlights um
summarization systems have actually you
know achieved broad applicability in in
many areas where we ingest content such
as summarizing emails or summarizing
meeting transcripts
and there's actually many more areas not
listed here i didn't actually put it on
the slide but a few months back a tool
called semantic scholar actually
developed a neural system for generating
summaries of scientific papers
which is something that i personally end
up using uh quite a bit as an example of
how humans can
interact with these technologies
but these modalities aren't actually
limited to text in or text out so
actually the classical nlg area that i
mentioned earlier is how the the task
used to be framed was actually around
what we now call data to text generation
uh so can you learn to compile or let's
say summarize the most interesting facts
from a from a table or a knowledge graph
or some type of data stream
that way humans can get the most most
interesting and salient content that's
being uh presented
in these data structures rapidly and in
an easier to ingest format than having
to look through the structures
themselves
um we've also seen a lot of recent work
in visual description
that tries to use language to describe
the content and images or videos
so around 2014 or so we start to see the
first neural nlg systems
um in the space and they've really you
know continued to mature in the last six
years and now we actually tackle much
more challenging description tasks such
as you know generating full descriptive
paragraphs of scenes uh or generating
streams of visual uh generating
descriptions for streams of visual
content such as such as in video uh
captioning and these these tools have
have really you know broad applicability
uh in different areas of ai
um and finally the last sort of
application i kind of want to mention is
that we've also started seeing lg
systems being developed in more
creative applications such as story
generation uh where ai systems can now
help humans write short stories blog
posts or even full books in some case uh
as as creative writing assistants um in
another area such as pose tree
generation
we can actually have kind of full
automated settings where you know you
can have ai agents that can generate
something like a sonnet and in fact
condition that on a lot of demands uh
through that are given through a user
interface
so you know i hope that by this point i
i've really given you a a look into the
breadth of nlg applications
and how they it sort of encompasses any
task
that you might think of that involves
production of text
and each of these tasks you know really
requires you know different algorithms
and different models and a different way
of designing the system to get right
but what they have in common is that a
lot of them are powered by next
generation uh advances uh in in deep
learning uh for for nlg
uh and the goal of today is to to really
give you the introduction uh to to these
topics that really allows you to
contribute to the next era of these
technologies and designing deep learning
systems uh for nlg
and so i think to start you know what
might be interesting to do uh is to
quickly recap topics that you may have
seen in previous lectures but which are
going to be uh very relevant today um
when we're trying to to design an nlg
system and what we're effectively trying
to do in the setting is you know take a
sequence of tokens as inputs
uh and produce new text that is
conditioned on this input and then what
we typically call the auto regressive
setting uh which is the most uh common
uh sort of text generation setting
we take these produced tokens of text
and we feed them back into our model to
generate the next token in the sequence
uh that we want uh to generate
but so to to really understand what's
going on in an auto regressive energy
system what we really need to start to
do is look at what happens for the
generation of an individual token since
further stages really depend on taking
that generated token and passing it back
in as input and doing the same thing
so what happens at a low level is that
your model takes in this this sequence
of inputs uh so these y's and it uh
computes a vector of scores uh using the
model itself
um and each index and that vector
corresponds to the score for a token in
your vocabulary so the only tokens that
your model is actually allowed to
generate
and then what you do is that you compute
a probability distribution over these
scores using what we call a soft max
function to compute a probability
estimate
for each token in your vocabulary given
the context that that precedes it
um and as a shorthand i'll just mention
that sometimes i'll remove the w from
this probability equation
but just know that when i write out the
probability of a token y at time t what
i mean is is the probability that y of t
uh is a particular word so it's it's
it's kind of a variable assignment
um
but so what actually is the output of
what we typically call a text generation
model at this point is actually this
vector of scores and then that vector
gets passed to the softmax function to
give us a probability distribution uh
over the set of tokens in the vocabulary
and then to actually generate a token we
can define what we call a decoding
algorithm that is a function that takes
in this this distribution uh p over all
the tokens of the vocabulary and you
know it defines a function for selecting
a token uh from this distribution as the
next token that is produced uh by our
nlg
system
and for that distribution to be
calibrated in such a way that it means
anything uh we need to train the model
to actually be able to do uh the task uh
so the most
common way of training text generation
models
uh is to use maximum likelihood training
and despite its name we don't actually
maximize likelihoods we actually
minimized negative log likelihoods
and what that actually is is just a a
multi-class classification task where
each word in our vocabulary uh is a
class that can be predicted uh by the
model and so at each step in the
sequence uh we're actually trying to
predict the class that corresponds to
the word that comes next uh in the
sequence of text that we're trying to
train on
and this word is often called the gold
or ground truth token as just kind of
interchangeable vocabulary that we use
um and another another uh term for this
training algorithm is teacher forcing so
you might see these expressions kind of
used interchangeably if you read papers
on this topic
but so in each step you're really
computing a loss term that is the
negative log likelihood of predicting
this gold token y1 at every step so in
these slides whenever you see an
asterisk next to a y
that means that this is a gold toke then
that comes from a training sequence
and you can do this for multiple steps
adding up the log likelihoods
along the way
eventually you're going to arrive at the
end of your of your gold sequence and
you'll be able to compute gradients with
respect to this summed loss term
for every parameter in your model which
allows you to update it
so that the next time around when you
see the sequence your model is more
confident in the probability
that the sequence is a correct sequence
given the same context it has seen
before
but most of this should just be a recap
from previous lectures on language
modeling and machine translation
um but now that we've got that out of
the way let's get to the fun part uh and
talk about some new topics uh the first
one of which is decoding which is
actually one of my favorite topics
in natural language generation research
so if you recall your decoding algorithm
is really the function that takes in
this this induced probability
distribution uh
from your model over the next possible
tokens that can be generated and selects
which one of those tokens should be
outputted
so once your model is trained this
distribution should be meaningful
and you want to be able to generate a
sensible next token
and then you can use these generated
next tokens so the blue y hat's here uh
as inputs in the next step of the model
which allows you to recompute a new
distribution decode a new token repeat
the process and eventually end up with a
full sequence that your model has now
generated given a fixed starting
sequence of text
and so let's talk a bit about the the
algorithms that we can use to decode
tokens from this distribution
so you've actually already seen some of
these in a previous lecture on neural
machine translation i believe
where you started off by by seeing a a
relatively simple decoding algorithm
that nonetheless remains very popular uh
arg max decoding and with ardmax
decoding you pretty much just take the
highest probability token um from your
distribution as the decoded token and
feed it back into the model uh for to
get the distribution of the next step
and you keep repeating this process and
it's very nice and it's very convenient
um and you've also i think learned about
beam search where you can scale up these
these greedy methods by doing a
a wider search uh over this the set of
tokens that follow uh the set of most
likely tokens that follow to try to find
a seek a subsequence that is a lower
overall
negative log likelihood even if it in
the intermediate step
it tends to be higher than what would be
the ardmax decoded token
and while these greedy methods work
great for
machine translation and in in other
tests as well such as summarization uh
they do tend to be problematic in many
other text generation tasks particularly
ones that end up being more open-ended
um so one of these big problems that
they have is that they often end up
repeating themselves
so here in this example from from
holtzman at all 2020 uh we can see that
after around 20 or sorry yet 60 tokens
or so of generation
the model really devolves into just
repeating the same thing over and over
again um this actually tends to happen a
lot uh in text generation systems uh
repetition was actually one of the
biggest problems that we that we tried
to tackle in text generation for many
years and still face to this day um and
you know i think it's worth taking a
look uh at why repetition happens from a
bit more analytically
so you can perhaps better understand the
interaction between your model uh and
your decoding algorithm
so just as a quick little visual
demonstration
here i'm showing you the step-by-step
negative log likelihoods from two
different language models uh one based
on recurrent neural networks and one
based on a transformer language model
called gpt uh and i'm showing this this
plot for a particular phrase i don't
know uh which for anyone who's worked in
chat bots uh has probably seen uh many
times
potentially even in nightmares um
it's not a very interesting plot uh
though you know what we do see is that
the transformer model does tend to be a
bit less confident in the probability of
each word than the recurrent neural
network does
uh what's more interesting though is
what happens if i repeat this same
phrase multiple times in a row
and one of the things that we notice
here is that the repetition of this
phrase
actually causes the token level uh
negative log likelihoods to get lower
and lower for each of these tokens which
actually means that the model is
becoming more confident that these are
the right tokens and that they're they
should probably follow the preceding
context as we generate it more times um
and this doesn't really subside as the
sequence gets longer uh and longer you
know if and as as you keep repeating the
same phrases again over and over again
the model becomes more and more
confident uh the next time around it
should say uh the same thing
um and you know while this actually kind
of makes sense and that if you you know
say the phrase let's say i'm tired 15
times
it's a fair bet that on a 16th time
you're actually going to say it again
it's not necessarily the behavior that
we want our generation systems uh to get
stuck in
another interesting thing to note here
as an aside is that uh this behavior is
actually less problematic in recurrent
neural networks uh than in transformer
language models uh so you can see that
for the lstm the curve flat flattens
after a certain point and so if you
remember in in perhaps a previous
lecture on why we might like transform
language models uh one of their benefits
is that they don't have the temporal
bottleneck of tracking a state
uh which um a recurrent neural network
tends to have and so the removal of that
bottleneck actually ends up making them
more prone to repetitive behavior when
you use greedy algorithms to decode
um but so what can we actually do to
reduce repetition since it's a pretty
big problem in these systems uh well
there are actually quite a few
proposed approaches in the last few
years some which i'll summarize here
which you know range from the
kind of hacky but surprisingly effective
don't repeat any engrams at inference
time
but there's also been training time
approaches to do it such as having a
loss function that minimizes the
similarity uh between hidden activations
at different time steps uh or coverage
loss that penalizes attending to the
same tokens over time uh so if you you
know change the inputs that your model
is allowed to focus on it's naturally
going to produce different text
or more recently an unlikelihood
objective that actually penalizes
outputting the same words
which we'll talk a bit more about later
but the truth is is that the problem
here
really lies in using greedy algorithms
uh in in the first place um in many
applications of you know human language
humans don't actually speak in a
probability maximizing way um so if you
look at this plot from
holtzman all 2020 it shows the per time
step probability of human written text
in orange um and beam search decoded
text in blue on the same uh graph and
what you can see is that beam search
decoded text tends to be very high
probability with little variance over
time and this makes a lot of sense you
know because it's literally trying to
maximize the probability of the
sequences that it produces um and a big
part of that is maximizing the you know
step-by-step probabilities of the tokens
that it uses uh but meanwhile we can see
that human written text is a lot more
variable often actually dipping into
very low probability territory um that
actually makes a lot of sense if we
could always you know predict human text
with high probability uh you know there
really be no listen no reason to listen
to each other speak since we'd know what
we were going to say
but so ultimately what we want to be
able to do is to match the uncertainty
of human language patterns in how we
decode text
which is why in in many applications
that tend to have this this higher
variability
sampling from these distributions has
kind of become a a go-to decoding method
particularly in creative generation
tasks
and so with sampling uh we take the
distribution over tokens that's produced
by our model and we generated we
generate a a token randomly
according to the probability mass that
is assigned to each uh potential option
so rather than doing any type of greedy
step we use the probability on each
token to give us a chance that that
token is generated
um
and so this does allow us to kind of get
much more
you know stochasticity and the types of
tokens that are that are generated
but a challenge that pops up here is
that these distributions tend to be over
a very large vocabulary and so even if
there's uh clearly tokens that have a
higher chance of being generated
the tail of the distribution can often
be spread over a much larger number of
possible tokens
and so this becomes a bit of a problem
because these tokens in the long tail
are probably completely irrelevant to
the current context so they shouldn't
have any chance of being selected
individually
but as a group it ends up that there's a
decent chance that you could output a
completely irrelevant token even if 90
of your probability mass is on relevant
tokens that means that you have a one in
10 chance of outputting something that
completely throws off your entire text
generation pipeline and is completely
inane
um so to mitigate this the field has
developed a a
a new set of algorithms that tries to
prune these distributions at inference
time
um and so top case sampling uh is kind
of the most obvious way to do this uh so
here we recognize that you know most of
the tokens in our vocabulary should have
no probability of being selected at all
so we just truncate the set of tokens
that we're allowed to sample from uh to
be the the k tokens uh with the um you
know highest amount of probability mass
of the distributions
and you know common values of k are
often 5 10 20 sometimes up to 100
but really it's a hyper parameter that
you end up setting as the designer of
this system
uh in general though what's important to
note is that the higher you make k
the more you'll be able to generate
diverse outputs which is good because
that's what we're trying to do but
you're also going to increase um you
know the chance of letting that long
tail seep in and generating something
that's completely irrelevant to the
current context
oh sorry meanwhile if you decrease k
your outputs are going to be safer from
these long tail effects but your text
may end up being boring and generic
because your sampling algorithm starts
to look a lot more greedy
in nature
um and this kind of shows the problem of
having a fixed k as the number of tokens
that you can generate from your
distribution um if your distribution a
certain point is pretty flat such as in
this example she said i never
blank you might not want to truncate a
lot of interesting options that you know
using a small value of k when there's so
many uh good choices that could fit uh
in this in in this potential context um
you know conversely in a different
example
uh you might want to cut off much more
than let's say your minimum k options uh
because only a subset of them end up
being quite suitable and you know higher
k than is really necessary lets that
long tail seep in and potentially you
know ruin your generation
and so um you know in response to this
top p or nucleus sampling is a way
around this issue so here instead of
sampling from a fixed number of tokens
at each step uh you sample from a fixed
amount of probability mass
and so depending on the flatness of your
distribution uh you end up including a a
variable number of tokens
that is that is kind of
dynamically changing depending on you
know how that probability mass is spread
across the distribution
and so you know to kind of describe this
visually if you have you know three
different distributions at a particular
step to generate a particular token
they're each going to prune a different
number of tokens from the available set
that you can sample from
depending on what the value of p is
and what the the peakiness of that
distribution actually ends up being
um so you know i keep talking about this
concept of flatness of a distribution uh
being kind of critical in understanding
how many tokens we can actually end up
sampling from
and in fact as we try to use sampling
algorithms we might find that the model
that we've learned
may not actually be producing
probability distributions that lend
themselves very nicely to using these
types of sampling algorithms you know
the distributions might be too flat they
might be too peaky
and in fact what we might want to do is
rescale those distributions to better
fit the decoding algorithm
that we might want to use
and we can do this with a uh a method
that's you know goes by a variety of
different names which i call temperature
scaling and here what you do is that you
apply a linear coefficient
to every score for each token
uh before you pass it through the
softmax that temperature coefficient is
the same for every token so it's not
dynamically changing amongst your
vocabulary uh it stays it stays the same
but what happens is that that that that
change ends up being amplified by the
softmax function
and what ends up happening is that if
your temperature coefficient is greater
than one you're actually going to make
your probability distribution uh much
more uniform
in in other words you're going to make
it flatter
meanwhile if your temperature
coefficient is less than one the scores
are going to increase which is going to
make your distributions more spiky and
make the probability mass kind of be
pushed towards the most likely
tokens
one last thing to note about temperature
is that it's not actually a decoding
algorithm it's just a way of rebalancing
your probability distribution uh so in
fact it can be applied to all of the
sampling algorithms i described before
and some greedy decoding algorithms as
well uh the only one whose behavior is
not affected uh by soft max temperature
scaling is uh ardmax decoding
because even though you change the
relative magnitudes of the of the
probability mass in your distribution
you don't actually change the relative
ranking amongst tokens in that
distribution so art max decoding will
give you the exact same output as before
but now that we're thinking about how we
might you know change the distribution
that's produced by our model we might
realize that we might want to change
more than the relative magnitudes i
mentioned um and also instead change how
they're ranked with respect to one
another maybe in fact you know our model
is not a a perfect um
approximation of you know what the
distribution over tokens should be you
know perhaps the training wasn't done
right or we didn't have enough training
data to actually make it well uh
calibrated and so if we decide that our
model isn't well calibrated for the task
that we're doing we may want to bring in
outside information
at decoding time
and so here i want to take talk a bit
about new classes of methods that let us
change
our model prediction distributions at
inference time rather than relying on a
on a fixed uh static model that's that's
only been trained once
um and a cool way of doing this that
came out last year uh is to actually use
uh k-nearest neighbor language models uh
which allow you to recalibrate your
output probability distribution
by using phrase statistics uh from let's
say a much larger corpus
and so you know what you do in this
method is that you initialize a large
database of phrases along with
vector representations for those phrases
and then at decoding time
you can search for the most similar
phrases in the database and so what you
do is that you know you take the
representation
of the context that you have from your
model and you compute a similarity
function with all the representations of
the phrases uh that you have stored and
you know based off the relative
differences amongst these different
phrases to your current context
uh you can compute a distribution over
these most similar phrases and then you
can take the next tokens that follow
these phrases
and add the statistics around those
phrases to the distribution
from your model and so this allows you
to really rebalance the probability
distribution uh that your model has
given you uh with this this this induced
distribution over phrases and
interpolate them together uh to get a
different estimate of how likely certain
words are
one question right now is um how do you
know what to cage cash
yeah so that's a really good question
um
i guess you know the the answer there is
that you could probably you know decide
on what might be a salient set of
phrases depending on let's say named
entities that you might be interested in
or uh phrases that you know that your
model's distribution doesn't handle very
well
but i'm i'm pretty sure in this work
they took every phrase
in their training corpus cached it and
then relied on very efficient algorithms
for doing this search uh over over over
representation similarity uh to actually
find the most likely ones um though they
did prune the number of phrases that
they actually used uh to make this
distribution uh the phrase distributions
that it wasn't uh over the entire corpus
um
so it's it's it's fantastic that we can
now rebalance these distributions if we
find that our model is is doing poorly
for uh you know particularly you know
this might be relevant if let's say
we're uh jumping into a new domain so
we've trained a nice big uh generation
model to to on wikipedia text and now
we're uh going into something that's you
know more uh more linked to stories you
know we might want to use this type of
system to get distributions from phrases
from there
but you know it's also possible that we
may not always have a good database of
phrases to help us calibrate output
distributions uh for all the types of
texts that we want to generate
and so luckily uh last year there's
there's also been uh you know new
approaches that look at doing this in a
gradient uh based way
and so the idea here is that you can
actually define some type of external
objective
using a a classifier that we typically
call a discriminator but in this figure
from from the paper that proposed it
they called an attribute model
and what that classifier does is that it
approximates some property that you'd
like to encourage your text to exhibit
as you decode uh so perhaps it's a
sentiment classifier because you are
working on a dialogue model uh that and
you want to encourage positive sounding
comments
uh so then what you do is that as you
generate text uh you input the output of
your text generation model uh to this to
this attribute model and there's some
some tricks on how you should do that
uh in order to actually uh not have it
be a discrete token that you provide to
the model but instead a distribution
over tokens
uh but the important thing is that you
know if you do this the the right way by
using the soft distribution of tokens as
inputs to the attribute model uh it's
going to be able to compute a score uh
for the sequence that it receives uh so
that you know if it's a sentiment
classifier it can evaluate how positive
of the sequence you provided to it
um and then what you can do is that you
can compute gradients with respect to
this property uh and back propagate
those gradients back to your text
generation model uh directly
um
and uh but instead of updating the
parameters which is what you would do
during training you instead update the
intermediate activations
at each layer of your model which you
can then forward propagate to compute a
new distribution over the sets of tokens
and so it's it's a neat trick that
allows you to do real-time distribution
updating based on some outside
discriminator
that's allowing you to update your
internal representations of the sequence
such that it hopefully generates
something more positive at the output in
this case
um so these these distribution
rebalancing methods either you know
based off of nearest neighbors search or
on using some type of discriminator uh
are are quite promising and interesting
but they also end up being quite
computationally uh intensive in the
first case you're essentially doing a
search over
you know thousands of phrases to
rebalance your distribution uh and the
second you're doing you know multiple
forwards and backwards passes at every
step to try and make the tokens exhibit
a particular behavior more um and
unfortunately neither of them actually
stop you from decoding bad sequences uh
either it's possible that even after you
rebalance your distribution you're still
generating something that looks terrible
um so in practice something that we
often use in text generation to improve
our sequence outputs
are what are called re-rankers and so
what we do here is that we actually
decode multiple sequences perhaps using
sampling uh or a a wider greedy search
uh say maybe ten
and then what we can do is that we can
initialize a score uh to evaluate the
sequences we produce and re-rank these
sequences according uh to the score
um and the simplest thing we can we can
do is to actually just score them uh by
the by the likelihood uh given given by
the model for example uh you know
especially if we're using a sampling
algorithm we might want to you know make
sure that we didn't generate something
that you know totally deviated from from
good text which would tend to have a
very high perplexity um so you know it's
perplexity is perhaps a good re-ranking
function um it's just important to be
careful as well that remember repetitive
sequences tend to have very low
perplexity as well and so if you you
know rank by perplexity you're likely to
just generate something you were trying
to avoid uh in the first case
um
but you know we can also uh make our
re-rankers evaluate more complex
behaviors so in the same way that we
could use gradient-based methods to
update our distributions to exhibit more
complex behaviors we can actually just
you know take those same attribute
models and use them as re-rankers to
re-rank a fixed set of sequences rather
than have them back propagate gradients
uh to the main
model
and so we can use them to rank things
such as style discourse factuality
logical consistency
um you know but you know just be careful
if your re-ranker ends up being poorly
uncalibrated um you know just because
you've trained a classifier to predict
whether a sentence makes a factual
statement doesn't actually mean that it
will be good at ranking different
factual statements with respect to one
another
and finally a nice thing about
re-rankers as well is that you can use
multiple re-rankers and parallel if
there's multiple properties you want to
score
and come up with let's say a weighted
average of different ranking scores uh
to decide on what might be the best
sequence according to different
properties
um
but so you know to recap what we've
talked about in terms of decoding you
know i just i want to mention that
decoding is is still a very challenging
problem in natural language generation
that we haven't really uh figured out
yet
our algorithms still don't you know
really reflect the way that humans
choose words when they speak
and our best approaches you know are
currently based on trying to calibrate
probability distributions produced by
models to perhaps be more representative
of human likelihood
but the truth is you know the human
language distribution is is quite noisy
and doesn't reflect the simple
properties that our decoding algorithms
often capture such as probability
maximization
but
different decoding algorithms do allow
us to perhaps inject biases that
encourage different properties of
coherent natural language generation
that's allowed us to make promising
improvements in this area as well
and in fact some of the most impactful
advances uh in nlg over the last few
years have really come from simple but
very effective modifications to decoding
algorithms uh because you can often have
impact across a very large number of
tasks by making a good change to a
decoding algorithm
uh but really there's there's still a
lot more work to be done in the space
and hopefully uh you know many of you
will be the ones to make these next
breakthroughs
i'm happy to take questions at this
point if any have popped up well here's
one question um how do you
evaluate how do you tell whether
rebalance distribution is better and if
i editorialize from there i guess you're
admitting on this slide that you can't
just look at the probability
yeah uh so yes you you can't just look
at the probability um i mean there is a
certain amount of of trust that happens
that if you don't trust that your ranker
is giving you a a better assessment of
whether you've produced a quality piece
of text perhaps you shouldn't be using
that re-rank here in the first place and
you know hopefully you've you've
actually means tested that re-ranker to
actually show that it has uh that it
improves the quality of text but we're
gonna talk a lot more about how you can
actually evaluate the quality of text uh
later on uh though i should warn you
ahead of time that the answers are not
as uh
not as direct and complete as you might
want them to be and in fact there's
there's a lot of room for
interpretation in how you would actually
do that
maybe you should go on about that later
but i guess people are puzzled on that
because there's a another question
that's yeah asking um
um i was saying that you said you don't
know how to make a model choose words
like a human
um
how do we model different humans
from different backgrounds etc
um
yeah that's that's that's a really good
question um
the answer to that is that you could
potentially try to you know do
um
do kind of uh fine-tuning on the
language distribution of a particular
human uh starting from let's say a
pre-trained language model since you'll
probably never have enough data uh to
only use a single human's outputs um or
you could try to do some of these
rebalancing methods that we've spoken
about to perhaps
use those to actually make your
distributions approach a particular
human's language distribution more
closely so in the gradient based methods
that i described i could perhaps train a
single language model only on my type of
language
even if i have a much larger one that's
trained on a much larger corpus of
language from different speakers
but then try to make it so that my model
ranks the outputs of the main model
i've got a question
yep
um so nucleus sampling and top case
sampling are really effective in
practice and you made the argument that
ah there are all these little tiny
things with very little probability mass
but it sums up to more probability mass
but
if it sums up to more probability mass
than they actually
should have under the real distribution
of human language shouldn't our models
have been trained to put less
probability mass on them and
so why don't we why aren't our language
models better in that case like why do
we have this issue if that's they
actually are getting more probability
than they should
um
yeah that's a really good question
um you know i think the answer to that
is that the way we train them which
which i'll get to in a bit is really
trying to
uh
is really trying to model the
distribution of human language as it
sees it in its training corpus and it's
actually uh surprisingly effective at
doing that um
but a
but at the same time when we actually
start to use these language models out
of the box in the nlg tasks that we work
with uh first of all there's there's
always you know slight deviations in the
distribution of text that we're actually
trying to model for the task we're doing
and what the large corpus we trained on
was in the first place uh which can make
these uh these decoding algorithms less
effective
um and you know the second thing i would
note is that even though these these
decoding algorithms are are quite
effective in practice um
they aren't doing what humans do when we
speak we're at no point when a human
speaks are we potentially trying to
maximize the probability of a potential
next token or randomly select a word
amongst a set of tokens we ultimately
have world models that drive how we
select the tokens that we choose to say
uh in order to make our points
and that's very different from what we
get in probabilistic language models um
now you know should we throw away
probabilistic language models no because
as you mentioned they end up working
quite well uh but at some point we also
do need to mitigate these differences
between how humans end up speaking and
how language models end up modeling
language
thanks
um
so you know now that now that john has
primed us perfectly for what comes next
um you know let's let's jump back into
to training these models um because you
know the the the pipeline you know that
i framed earlier being you know you
train your model then you choose your
decoding algorithm uh depending on
properties you're interested in
um is is is great but the truth is
there's interactions between your
decoding model and your training
algorithm that you might want to be
thinking about during training which is
not really what we're doing right now
um and so if you recall that the
training algorithm that we've proposed
up to this point
is one where we just try to minimize the
negative log likelihood
of the next token in a sequence
given the preceding ones uh at every
step um and you know as i mentioned this
actually works pretty well for training
auto-regressive models of human language
uh but it actually causes uh a few
issues which which john uh hinted at um
so in the next few slides i'm gonna i'm
gonna talk a bit about these issues and
then highlight some some training
solutions to these problems uh that i
found uh interesting or that i think are
important uh from from the last few
years
um so the first issue is actually one
that i hinted at in the last section uh
which is that uh training with maximum
likelihood uh tends to discourage uh
textual uh diversity and i showed this
sequence uh on a slide earlier as an
example of greedy algorithms being prone
to generating repetitive uh sequences
which you know is just about the the
worst form of diversity uh that you
could that you could get
um but you know greedy algorithms are
just trying to maximize the probability
of the sequences that they produce so it
can really only be prone to repetitive
and undiverse phrases uh if those
phrases are scored highly by the model
uh to begin with
and that ends up being one of the issues
with maximum likelihood training is that
it tends to end up favoring generic
expressions because those are the ones
that are you know often the most likely
in human language uh production
um but you know as we all know and as i
mentioned earlier human language
production isn't about maximizing the
likelihood of the words that we produce
so even though we might produce generic
phrases more often than ungeneric
phrases that's not the goal that we're
setting out with when we speak there's a
lot more to communication that really
isn't synthesized by a training
objective that tries to maximize um you
know probability over the human language
that's being read uh so how can we end
up mitigating this problem
um so
you know an interesting approach that i
really like that came out last year was
was actually um you know proposed by by
wellick at all
which was called unlikelihood training
and so here what you do is that you
actually discourage the production of
particular tokens by the model in
certain contexts and so what happens
that this loss term here decreases as
the probability of the y-neg tokens
decreases so for any token that you
don't want to generate as the
probability of generating that token
goes down so so so does the loss term
which means that you're not actually
updating the model as much uh for the to
for this particular behavior
uh what's important though is that you
still have your t-shirt forcing
objective uh so what's going to happen
is that the model is going to learn to
capture both the distribution of
language from the training corpus which
it needs to do to
learn how to generate text
but also it's going to learn how to not
say particular words that you might not
want it to
um
and then what you can do is that you can
set this list of words that you don't
want the model to generate uh to
actually be words that you've already
generated before and so in essence
you're you're teaching the model to not
say the same things again and that's
just naturally going to limit the amount
of repetition that your model is going
to be able to spit out
and you're going to be able to generate
more diverse texts as a result as well
but a second and very important issue
that comes from training with with
maximum likelihood is um you know what
we often call exposure bias
which is that the context that we train
on uh to generate the next token are
gonna look different from the ones that
we see at generation time and so why
might that be
um well so what happens during training
is that we always get a token from a
gold document or human text as it puts
it's the gold sequence as we call it
but then during generation we're feeding
our previously generated tokens
back into the model as the input um
rather than these these teacher force
tokens uh that are that are from uh the
gold documents
and so that set of tokens is actually
quite affected by things like the
distributions produced by our model uh
and the decoding algorithm we use uh to
get tokens um and so you know can this
end up being a problem uh well yes
because as we've seen before the types
of text that our model generates uh are
often you know not a very close
approximation of human language patterns
in the training set
and so there's going to be an imbalance
between the type of text that our model
has learned to predict uh learn to to
predict and to expect to see and the
type of text that it uh will see once we
actually start decoding and so once your
model starts receiving its own inputs
which are going to deviate from the
distribution of text to expect it's
going to be very challenging for it to
be able to generate coherent texts going
forward because it's not going to really
know how to synthesize its own
information that it's generated
um and so there's a variety of ways to
try to counter this exposure bias issue
uh and many more that that continue uh
to come out um you know unfortunately
there's not really enough time to talk
about all of them so i've added slides
to discuss uh two of them that are based
on semi-supervised learning here
um
but i really want to focus more on two
other
approaches that i personally find very
interesting um the first is called
sequence rewriting
and so you know in this setting your
model first learned to retrieve a
sequence
from an existing database of human
written
prototypes so it's kind of like our
nearest neighbor decoders earlier where
we cached a bunch of phrases here you
cache a bunch of sequences that might be
similar to the one that you're supposed
to produce for this new situation
and then what we do is that once we take
this sequence and retrieve it we learn
to edit it uh by doing things like
adding removing or or modifying tokens
uh to more accurately reflect the
context that we're actually given rather
than the one that this original sequence
uh was was designed for in the first
place
and so we can still use an algorithm
here that tries to maximize likelihood
for training uh but because there's this
sort of latent variable of retrieving
the right prototype that's involved uh
it makes it less likely that our that
our generated text ends up suffering
from exposure bias because you're
already starting from something that
looks more like a training sequence that
you might have seen
um another general class of uh of
possibilities we can do is to let our
model learn to
generate text by learning from its own
samples
um and you know this naturally maps
itself nicely to reinforcement learning
uh which is actually one of my uh
favorite ways uh to to to learn how to
generate text um in this setting uh
you're gonna cast your text generation
model as a markov decision process
where your state s is the model's
representation of the preceding context
that you see
your actions a are the words that can be
generated
your policy is the decoder
and your rewards are are provided by
some type of external score
and here you can you can learn many
different behaviors for your text
generation model
by rewarding it uh when it exhibits
those behaviors
and so to kind of quickly join this
framing uh with the perspective of the
text generation models that we've seen
so far uh you're going to be taking
actions by you know sampling words
um hat y from from the distribution
and then you're going to feed them back
into the input to get a new state which
is you know what we've been doing at
every point
uh what's different though is that uh as
you generate text you're using some
external reward function to compute
rewards for each token that you generate
so you're rewarding every action that
you take
and then you scale the sample loss
uh on this on this particular token that
you generate uh by by this reward which
is going to encourage the model to
generate the sequence in similar context
if the reward is high
to put it very clearly um you're
minimizing the negative log likelihood
of your sample token so here it's not a
gold token notice the hat that is on the
y expression in the reward function
um
and then uh you're going to compute a
reward for that token and scale this
negative log likelihood by that reward
so if the reward is high the model is
going to be more likely to generate this
same sequence in a similar context in
the future if the reward is low it will
be less likely
but this sort of brings up a natural
question you know what can we actually
use as a reward to encourage the
behaviors we want in this text
generation system
that's really up to you as you design
this your generation pipeline
a common
practice in the early days of using rl
for text generation uh was to set the
reward to be the final evaluation metric
that you were going to evaluate on
and so here instead of having a unique
reward for each generated token at every
time step you would just take the final
sequence score that you get and reward
every token in the generated sequence
with that value
and
this was absolutely magical
you would set your evaluation metric as
the reward and you'd end up learning to
get more reward because that's what rl
algorithms do which in turn means that
you were learning to generate sequences
that do better on your evaluation metric
so lg benchmark scores were shooting
through the roof
we were making uh real progress but it
was actually all a lie um you know turns
out as i'll talk about later evaluation
metrics particularly for text generation
are just approximations
and it's not always clear that
optimizing to those approximations
is going to lead to more and better uh
coherent text generation uh instead
often times what ends up happening is
that it just learns to exploit the noise
in the evaluation metric
and in fact in their large uh
work where they introduced google's
neural machine translation system in
2016 uh you know google researchers
generally found that uh training machine
translation models with rl and blue
scores as rewards
uh didn't actually improve the
translation quality at all even if it
did lead to higher blue scores
but so designing your reward function uh
is is a very important uh problem uh nrl
for actually learning the behavior uh
that you want um and i've listed some
some some cool work here on how you can
actually learn to tie fairly complex
behaviors uh to reward functions by
actually uh initializing the scores they
use as rewards as neural networks that
you know get trained on an auxiliary
task ahead of time but can then be used
to provide scores as rewards to the
system that you produce uh so to go back
to our example earlier of trying to
create a
dialogue agent that is very positive and
only says positive things you could use
a sentiment classifier
to produce a reward for the sequences
that you generate
and so that's a lot of fun
unfortunately despite all the fun that
you can have using rl to train text
generation engines there's a bit of a
dark side too uh which is that
reinforcement learning algorithms uh can
be notoriously uh unstable
and so to get these text generation
systems to learn with rl you often have
to be thorough in
tuning different dials in your model
setup
accurately
there's many of them two of them that i
think are worth mentioning or one that
you always need to pre-train with
teacher forcing
you generally can't train with
reinforcement learning from scratch
and also you need to provide some type
of baseline reward
that your model should be achieving
so for example blue score which i
described earlier is always a positive
value
unless it's zero but that means that if
you use it alone as a reward every
single sequence that you sample ends up
you know uh being encouraged in the
future so what you want to have is some
type of baseline that is an expectation
of how much reward you should be getting
which can be subtracted from the reward
that you actually get so you can
discourage certain behaviors as well
um one last note about this is that
neural networks are quite good at
finding the easiest way to learn
something
so you know if there's a way to exploit
your reward function
uh it'll find a way to do it
particularly that's easier than learning
the behavior that you want it to learn
um so
something to to remember that's kind of
important if you try to use
reinforcement learning for text
generation systems
particularly because there's such a
large accent action space uh for of
words that it can generate to try to
accomplish certain behaviors
um so you know to end this section i
just want to start off by saying that in
general we still use teacher forcing as
a as a primary means of learning to
generate
coherent text
it has diversity issues but it still
lets
us learn a model with with decent text
generation
abilities
one thing i haven't focused too much on
in this lecture is the type of model
that you can use uh to actually generate
text uh because they tend to be less
universal and much more designed to to
very specific end tasks
but in general a common approach in nlg
is to try to design a neural
architecture uh that allows um
your your model to to be perhaps less
sensitive to the problems of teacher
forcing or to address them with
additional loss terms that are perhaps
task specific
uh exposure bias though is a problem
everywhere uh pretty much regardless of
your of your neural architecture um and
you know to to kind of mitigate it you
can either train your model to be more
resistant uh to its own distribution
changes through things like
semi-supervised learning or you can uh
uh change your uh your your pipeline so
that you're learning to make
modifications to an existing sequence
that you retrieve from your training set
rather than trying to learn how to
generate sequences uh from scratch um
uh the caveat there is that you know as
the type of text that you're generating
gets longer and longer uh doing this
this kind of retrieval and editing uh
becomes just as challenging as
generating from scratch in many cases
um and finally you can use reinforcement
learning as another means of of of
learning from your own examples
and you know and in effect you can also
use it to encourage different behaviors
than just likelihood maximization um but
this type of learning can end up being
quite unstable and unless your reward is
well shaped uh the model can often learn
to exploit it
are there um
so online language simulators where you
can train
with rl online or are you only talking
about training offline
um no in this setting we're generally
talking about training offline so you
you you train it all ahead of time and
then you use your model uh as it's been
trained the first time around
okay yeah so uh now this we've we've
finally reached the section that i
hinted at earlier on and on a very
important topic uh evaluation um
which you know to be honest is something
that we should be thinking about uh
before we even start designing a model
or or training algorithm or or a
decoding algorithm it's you know how can
we actually check uh that our method is
is how can we act how are we actually
going to evaluate that our method is
even working
um and today i want to talk a bit about
three types of evaluation metrics uh so
first we'll talk about automatic eval
metrics
because generally you need to be able to
rapidly prototype and diagnose failures
in your model so it's essential to be
able to have this this quick feedback
even if it's very uh coarse
and in automatic evaluation metrics
um you know we've we've traditionally
used what i'm calling content overlap
metrics uh which focus on how much a
sequence explicitly resembles another
sequence usually in terms of word or
phrase matching
uh lately there's also been a new
automatic evaluations that are that are
model based where we try to use advances
in embeddings and neural models to
define more implicit similarity measures
between sequences
and finally we'll talk a bit about human
evaluations which are kind of the gold
standard uh
of of of evaluating text generation
uh but they also uh do have downsides
that uh that we'll get to as well um and
i just want to note that some of these
slides here are actually repurposed from
slides from asleep
who's a leading expert on nlg evaluation
uh but so let's jump in uh so content
overlap metrics generally compute an
explicit similarity score between two
sequences uh the one that's been
generated by your model and some gold
standard uh reference sequence
that was attached to the to the inputs
that you had so in other words a
sequence that you know was an
appropriate uh generation for the inputs
uh
you you had
um and these these metrics are often a
popular starting point because they're
fast and uh very efficient uh which is
their main benefit as long as you have a
reference sequence to compare to uh you
can you know compute these scores
rapidly to get feedback
and i'm going to categorize them into
two zones here first engram overlap
metrics that compute different functions
of word and word like overlap
and semantic overlap metrics which
involve more complex overlap functions
based off semantic structures
unfortunately besides being fast and
efficient
um most engram overlap metrics uh don't
actually give you
uh a great approximation of sequence
quality uh a lot of times um they're
already you know not ideal for something
like machine translation where there can
be multiple ways to translate the same
sequence with things like like synonyms
and they get you know progressively much
worse for tasks that are more open-ended
than mt
so for example in summarization
you know the longer output texts make it
naturally harder to measure something
using word match
um and it's something like dialogue it's
incredibly open-ended and in fact you
can have
multiple responses
to a particular utterance that you know
uh mean the same thing but don't use any
common words
and so we can illustrate this with a
simple fairly contrived example uh where
you you know have a dialogue context
utterance that asks a question such as
you know are you going to antoine's
incredible cs224 and lecture
a completely uh unbiased reference text
from you know derived from a human
and then a dialogue agent that spits out
different answers such as uh yes which
gets a pretty high score on our engram
overlap metrics
or you know it which already scores a
lot lower despite depicting you know the
exact same idea or yup which actually
gets a score
of zero
meanwhile a completely incorrect answer
heck no uh gets the highest score
out of all of them which kind of points
to the issue you know when you use
engram overlap measures um in a lot of
applications you're going to be missing
the salient elements of what the
generated sequence should capture and
instead you know be getting stylistic uh
similarities between texts even as you
miss the most important context
and if you prefer empirical validations
to contrived examples uh it's actually
been shown that many dialogue evaluation
metrics don't really correlate well with
human judgments at all
and this gets worse as your sequence
length increases typically so with an
open-ended task like story generation uh
you can
get improved scores by just matching a
whole lot of stop words that have
nothing to do with the content of the
story itself
we also have another category of overlap
metrics that i'll call semantic overlap
metrics because they don't necessarily
tie directly to the words you used but
instead try to create conceptual
representations of the generated and
reference outputs instead uh so the
center one here spice for example uh
creates a scene graph of your um
of your generated text and then compares
that
to your to your reference caption uh to
see how similar this this more semantic
representation ends up being
um
but clearly there's there's some
limitations to how well explicit content
overlap metrics can do particularly as
we start thinking about more open-ended
tasks uh so in response over the last
years there's been a focus on using
model based metrics whose
representations
uh come from uh you know machine
learning models and where they can be
used to actually evaluate the fidelity
of generated text
i mean these are nice because there's no
more needing explicit matches between
words in your reference and generated
text instead you can rely on much more
implicit notions of similarity
that you get from word embeddings
um and so you know there's been a lot of
of models uh develop uh in this area
some of the original ones kind of
focused on uh you know defining
composition functions over the
embeddings of words in your generated
and reference sequences and then
computing a
distance between the compositions of the
two sequences
some more um you know so some more
involved takes on this idea are things
like word movers distance where here you
actually try to map word vectors in both
your generated and reference sequences
uh into pairs with one another uh so
each you know word vector is paired to
another work vector in the opposite
sequence and the distance between them
is computed and then you allow the the
the evaluation metric to actually
compute the optimal matchings between
these pairs of words such as the total
distance is minimized
and bird score which has
become quite popular uh over the last
year or so as an evaluation metric is
pretty much just word movers distance
but using contextualized bird and bird
embeddings uh to compute these distances
um sentence movers similarity is kind of
another extension of word movers uh
similarity that adds sentence embeddings
from recurrent neural networks to this
distance optimization and that allows it
to be more effective for evaluating
let's say long multi-sentence text
as opposed to just single single
sentences
and finally uh last year uh there was a
new model named blurt which is actually
a regression model that's based on birds
and here it takes a pair of sentences uh
the reference on the generated one and
returns a score that indicates to what
extent the candidate is grammatical and
conveys the meaning of the reference
text
um so you know we can we can talk about
a lot more evaluation metrics that are
computed automatically and you know
there's there's far more of them than i
actually mentioned though they do tend
to fit in those two categories that i
described
but it's it's important to remember that
at the end of the day the true mark of
an lg system's performance is whether
it's valuable to the human user that has
to interact with it or read the text
that's produced from it
and unfortunately automatic metrics tend
to fall short of replicating uh human
opinions of the quality of uh generated
text
and that's why you know for this
reason uh human evaluations are are
viewed as the most important form of
evaluation for text generation
systems
almost all work in nlg
generally include some form of human
evaluation particularly if the task is
more open-ended
and if it doesn't um well you know let
me be frank you should probably be
skeptical of any claim that's being made
by that work
um
and finally uh you know another use of
human evaluations is that in addition to
to evaluating model performance
you can also use them to actually train
new uh machine learning models that are
meant to be uh evaluate that are meant
to serve as evaluation scoring functions
uh themselves
um so uh i guess the you know the main
thing to mention about human evaluations
uh since you know we could talk about
them for a while uh is that they're both
very simple but also very difficult uh
to run
you you know they're simple because you
generally just need to find judges and
ask them to rate an intrinsic dimension
of the quality of your generated text uh
so you have to define a set of criteria
that you decide is important for the
task that you're designing a system for
and that can be things like fluency
where you just you know measure things
like grammar spelling word choice does
this actually look like human language
uh factuality does the text accurately
reflect facts that are you know
described in the context uh you know
common sense does it sort of follow the
logical rules of the world that we might
uh expect
um but once you once you've defined
these criteria you can have humans
evaluate the generated text uh for how
well it actually um produces text that
uh that
that caters to the to these particular
criteria
uh one thing to note here is that you
know while these you know dimensions are
common and repeated across different
evaluations uh they can you know often
be referred to by other names and you
know explain to evaluators in in
different terms
um and be measured in different ways and
in fact one of the problems with human
evaluations is that across works they
tend to be uh very unstandardized which
can make the replication of human
results uh quite difficult and that's
why when you read text generation papers
you rarely see a comparison of human
evaluation scores between two different
studies
even if they evaluated the same
dimensions
um
but you know
another set of issues with human
evaluations uh beyond the fact that
they're slow expensive and
unstandardized is that you know humans
themselves aren't uh actually uh perfect
um
you know i guess there's a few negatives
that i can say about humans um you know
even though
we're all humans is that we tend to not
be very consistent folks
uh you know often changing our minds
about how we view something uh depending
on something as as you know trivial as
the time of day
um you know we don't always reason uh in
the way that uh we're expected to when
presented with with a task such as
evaluating something we can lose
concentrated lose concentration and not
really be focused on what we're doing
and you know we can often misinterpret
uh what let's say human evaluation is
asking us to do such that we inject our
own biases into the task
um and you know on top of all these
things you know when we run human
evaluations we're also dealing with the
fact that one of the big motivators that
our human judges have is to do the task
as quickly as pos as possible uh which
isn't a great mix particularly if we
want them to to really give us high
quality uh ratings
uh but you know humans are kind of the
best thing that we that we have to
actually give us the the most accurate
assessments of whether text generation
systems are are doing well uh so we so
we do the best that we can
um i'm actually gonna skip this slide
but i mentioned earlier that you know
one of the things that we can also do is
use human ratings to uh to train models
uh to actually predict scores uh for for
text itself um and so uh two systems
that that do some things along these
lines i've provided citations to here so
that you can take a look at them if
you're curious later on
um
but so uh you know the takeaways i kind
of want you to to get from this section
uh are that you know evaluation is quite
hard um and particularly in text
generation
so content overlap metrics do provide a
good starting point for evaluating the
the quality of generated text um you
know if you run these zen gram overlap
metrics and they show scores that are
worse than they should be that's the
first sign that you that you have a
problem uh but they're generally not not
good enough uh on their own
uh model-based metrics tend to be uh you
know more correlated with human
judgments than content overlap once
particularly as the tasks uh become more
open-ended uh such as you know dialogue
and storytelling but the downside there
is that they're they're not very
interpretable uh you know unlike with a
content overlap metric where you can you
know say exactly oh this is why this
score is this way it's because these
words match up with these words with a
model based metric you you get a much
more implicit
uh definition of similarity which you
know while useful is also less uh
interpretable
uh human judgments are absolutely
critical
because
even if they're inconsistent
and sometimes don't do the tasks that
you want them to humans are actually
able to intrinsically evaluate
dimensions that we
that we don't even know how to formulate
using any type of automatic metric
um but lastly slightly unrelated to what
i've spoken about this section you know
i just i just want to say that the
number one evaluator of any nlg system
that you create uh should should really
be you um you know a a look at your
model's outputs as perhaps you you do a
project that involves nlg
can really be worth days weeks and
sometimes months of staring at
evaluation metrics that are that are
perhaps a bit uninformative
so if you design an lg systems make sure
to evaluate your own generations very
consistently
um
so in this last section
i think it's quite important to talk
about
ethical topics in
natural language generation as well
because you know ultimately while nlg uh
really allows us to tackle new and
interesting applications um you know if
we're not capable we can end up
deploying fairly dangerous and harmful
systems um and as a warning i just want
to say that you know some of the content
on the next few slides can uh you know
is going to potentially be quite
uncomfortable um but i think it's
important to make very clear how these
systems can can go very very wrong
um and without picking on a particular
example um i i do perhaps think that you
know the uh you know the one of the most
famous examples of this was the tay
dialogue chat bots which was released
onto twitter uh in in 2016. um and
within 24 hours it had started you know
making some very nasty comments that uh
that exhibited racist sexist
anti-semitic you know white supremacist
uh leanings which you know is ultimately
probably not what the designers of tay
had in mind um so what actually ended up
uh going wrong with tay
well you know here's the thing
tay behaved
exactly as we should have expected it
would
it was designed to learn to exhibit the
conversational patterns of the users
that it interacted with
and it did that you know nlg models are
very good at capturing the language
distribution of their training examples
that's that's been the one thing that
we've been remarkably consistent on um
you know over the last few years and it
turns out if they're like training
examples end up having toxic content
they will learn to repeat that content
and this is perhaps no clearer than if
you look at what pre-trained language
models have to say
about let's say different demographics
so if you remember you know large
pre-trained language models uh that
underlie many modern lg systems uh
they're trained on massive corporate
texts which are often opaque and crawled
from online resources
if it turns out that those corpora have
toxic content the language models are
going to learn it and in fact make it
even worse
and then it turns out that if you prompt
these language models for for certain
pieces of information
it can spit out that toxic content um
you know showing you know very different
opinions across you know gender
races sexual orientations
um now you know i can see that it would
actually be rare to ask a language model
to weigh in with their opinions on this
matter
but you do have to ask yourself if this
type of information is encoded in the
model in some way in what other ways
could these learned patterns end up
being reflected by this model once it's
actually deployed in practice
and that kind of leads us to the second
problem with these language models
we actually don't really know how
information ends up being learned and
encoded by them which means that we
don't have a rigorous understanding of
what types of inputs are going to
trigger what types of outputs
and in fact wallace it all showed in
their emnlp 2019 work that this was a
big problem because if you prime these
models with particularly adversarial
inputs they would generally devolve
immediately into producing very toxic
content
in other words what it took 24 hours to
learn how to do these systems can kind
of do out of the box if primed with the
wrong examples
and unfortunately the wrong examples
um you know
end up you know being a lot less nasty
than we might have expected a lot less
nasty than the ones on the previous
slide uh at the at the very least um but
you know in a work at em nlp findings uh
last year
you know a research group showed that
you know much more innocuous looking
inputs could actually prime these
language models to go on pretty toxic
diatribes uh as before
it wasn't as consistent as in the as in
the previous work but it was still
often enough
um and these examples really go to show
that we need to be to be careful with
how these systems are deployed
if you have an nlg system you need
safeguards to stop it from outputting
harmful content
and this goes beyond the examples of
toxic and bi toxicity and device i've
shown today you know a model that can be
primed to generate incorrect or
unfactual information can be can be
quite dangerous too
and also nlg models shouldn't be
deployed without an understanding of who
its users will be
and there's always going to be
adversarial users for any model that you
create even if you
can't think of them in the moment
and that leaves us the final point um
which is that you know the advances in
nlg have really
uh you know allowed us to
to build text production systems for
many new applications um you know as we
do this though it's it's important to
ask you know does the content that we're
building a system to automatically
generate um you know for for for easy
human ingestion um you know does it
really need to be generated
automatically
and i think a a good example of this is
the work of zellers at all at nurbs 2019
which you know showed off the potential
dangers of fake news generators uh from
pre-trained uh language models i i
actually thought this was a great work
and it highlighted um you know many of
the defenses that you could be developed
against a fake news generation's
system
but you know the point more is more so
that you should always imagine
that any tool that you create could be
used in a negative way
so a storytelling
an lg system can also potentially be uh
you know repurposed uh to do fake news
generation um
and you should really always ask
yourself whether the positive
applications of a particular technology
outweigh the potential negative ones um
and that turns out to often uh not be an
easy question
um
so i guess as concluding thoughts uh for
today
um you know i i just want to mention
that uh
you know
if you start interacting with nlg
systems in practice uh you're you're
quickly going to see the the the fairly
large limitations uh that they that they
tend to have um even in tasks where
we've you know achieved a larger amount
of progress
at building systems that that can do the
task fairly well there's still a lot of
improvements that can be made to make
them even better
in pretty much any nlg task at the same
time evaluating it effectively remains a
huge challenge we often have to to rely
on humans to give us the best estimates
of how well our system is doing
uh and so a an area where a large
improvement uh would really you know
kind of bootstrap larger improvements
and many other areas of nlg would be to
find better automatic evaluation um for
foreign systems
um on the other hand on a very you know
optimistic note i do want to say that
with the advent of large-scale language
models
uh you know deep energy research hasn't
hasn't been reset but it's never been
easier to jump in the space and and
start playing around with the systems
and
uh and designing cool new tools uh that
can that can that can you know help
humans ingest content and information uh
more rapidly and more uh efficiently uh
and as a result i think that it's you
know one of the most exciting areas of
nlp uh to work in um and i think that uh
that you know if you start working in it
as well you'll feel the same way and i
would encourage you to do so
so thanks a lot for having me today
it was really exciting